what a Smosh means so much to you like
me you're like really sad they're the
only ones who can actually get you up
yeah
it's been crazy and crazy the non-stop
train of craziness I want to say that
it's a crazy train yes
honestly we boys we went from rehearsal
at 7:45 a.m. to going back to our room
to change into our clothes for our main
stage performance then after the
mainstage performance we had a run over
to our signing and after that we had to
go immediately to film lunchtime
you know just watching someone to work
it makes you want it to work really bad
don't let just work so we're the owners
mine boy okay ready got that yes there
okay
food battle is sort of we've always
wanted to create a game that sort of
centered around this this fictional game
that Anthony played in a food battle
years ago 2009 and we never we never
really knew how we were going to do it
and then but in the discussion yeah the
discussion of IndieGoGo came up and we
were like okay so maybe that we can
actually make this work and then with
the help of our viewers you know giving
us their input on what they want to see
and just getting people excited about
about the project it's it's really been
an experience we've never done anything
like this so it's sort of a learning
experience you know but it's fun
I heard that the tickets were sold out I
was so depressed and everything and some
all of a sudden his food battle game
showing up and it was very a big
surprise when I got $2,000 the PERT
problem faces right now go for the house
there is that three way from can you
it was like a once-in-a-lifetime thing
that she really wanted to do which is
it's crazy really yeah yeah I I was when
we put that perk up I'm like no one's no
one's gonna get this is just gonna make
us look pathetic having this thing up
here that no one's gonna get and then
she got it like the same day yeah she
was she was super stoked we yeah we said
we just did the most random hoses up
there it was it got a little weird yeah
but it was fun it was fine one yeah and
she I think she had a lot of fun perfect
like everything belonged really happened
and was it worth it definitely you know
that's the cool thing about IndieGoGo
it's not like we're forcing people that
give us money right where we're giving
them something that they want right and
and that's the cool sort of trade-off is
that we're able to create something that
they will hopefully enjoy and I'm pretty
sure they will because this game is
gonna kick ass and it's gonna be free
yeah yeah they said like I got $200
where's my merchandise
and I just take it out what I wanted and
I got the best photos in the world that
it's gonna be emailed to my mom
this week has been like the craziest
week ever I don't think I have had a
moment without a headache it's a good
headache yeah it's a good yeah it's like
okay we got to you know do the game the
magazine and yeah I mean we're doing a
lot of stuff they don't have to do what
we think everyone will really like so
we're just pushing ourselves to do as
much as you can hello Carly Sophie Katie
Tiffany yeah and it's so crazy with with
VidCon because you think that you know
it's just just some people probably from
around the area that are coming but we
were meeting people that that came from
Australia from Spain Denmark people have
been like they're like oh I flew 12
hours and one of the only people I
wanted to meet with you guys and that's
the weird sort of thing about about
VidCon you know is that there's these
people that are this passionate about
about the space and it's something that
you know you might you might see in
something bigger like comic-con you know
but now it's happening in in our space
which is pretty crazy